[Musik]
hi was geht meine Damen und Herren mein
Name ist Luca und ich befinde mich heute
mal wieder nicht alleine sondern
mit Jule ja genau das ist das ist Jule
okay cool auf jeden Fall hatte ich die
glorreiche Idee dass Jule einfach mal in
einem 1-Euro-Laden hier nebenan gehen
könnte und sich dort einfach mal alle
produktivster gibt Koch kaufen kann nein
auf jeden Fall wird Jule jetzt von mir
20 € bekommen und mit diesen 20 €
irgendwelche Artikel im ein Euro
Geschäft kaufen gehen und dann werdet
ihr mich hier Wiedersehen in meiner
Wohnung wie ich das auspacke aber jetzt
seht ihr erstmal Jule wie sie das
Einkaufen geht
[Musik]
mir wurde gerade gesagt dass ich hier
nicht bin
ja ich mache das jetzt einfach trotzdem
[Musik]
hätte ich gedacht dass es hier mehr
Sachen gibt also ich finde halt echt
nicht so viel
[Applaus]
ich mag Hunde Hunde
tut mir leid dass ich das nicht so gut
mache aber hier sind voll viele Leute
und ich habe das ehrlich gesagt auch
noch nie gemacht
[Musik]
ich kaufe
Luftschlangen
Party
oder ist die Frau ich kaufe ein Mini
Billardspiel weil Luca Billard glaube
ich mag also ich bin jetzt fertig und
ich habe 22 € 25 bezahlt also ein
bisschen zu viel ich gehe jetzt auf
jeden Fall wieder zurück ich hoffe ich
habe nicht
komplette Scheiße gekauft mich gucken
alle Leute an weil hässlich bin aber
mit den Sachen wieder angekommen und ich
packe jetzt aus
warte auch
Alter krasse hört ihr auch das
Meeresrauschen
also meine Damen und Herren Judith
wieder angekommen aus dem Geschäft ich
bin froh dass du es überlebt hast
ich habe die Datei noch nicht gesehen
wie sie darum gelaufen ist oder was sie
hier gekauft hat das heißt ich werde
jetzt einfach mal die Hand nehmen hier
reingreifen und das erste Produkt was
würde mir mitgebracht hat ist
ich kaufte keinen Scheiß Hund kaufen
nein
natürlich bedanke mich und wir machen
weiter mit dem nächsten Produkt meine
Damen und Herren das nächste was mich
Jule mitgebracht hat ist ein was
soll ich mir hiermit in die Haare
Klemmen ja bist du bescheuert guck mal
der Held das nicht toll
der hält wie Olli kann die Bälle im Tor
fest ne
oh nein also auf jeden Fall an der
Stelle schon mal Danke Jule für das
Hundefutter für unsere nicht existenten
Hund und den Hut für unser nicht
existentes Baby als nächstes Produkt
meine Damen und Herren haben wir
das ist kein Ring was soll das denn sein
[Musik]
ich habe ein Fahrrad also wenn ich
demnächst durch die Innenstadt laufe und
mir das ein bisschen zu voll ist kann
ich einfach meinen Ring Auspacken
einfach
entschuldigt
[Musik]
okay Alter ich dachte halt wirklich
zuerst das irgendwie so ein Lolli wäre
oder so den ich mir umbinden kann und
dann kann ich den so schmecken aber es
ist einfach
[Musik]
den kann man auch gut sein halt die
Fresse benutzen als nächstes Produkt
meine Damen und Herren würde ich sagen
nehmen wir mal das ganz fette was hier
drin liegt das hat sich kein Euro
gekostet oder ich will noch nicht was es
ist hier steht nur nicht für wie toll
was denn
das der Titel hat 1 €. ja kann ich was
dafür zweimal ein Euro gekostet dann
also ich sehe noch nicht genau was es
ist aber hier steht achtung nicht für
Kinder unter 3 Jahren
dann machen wir das nächste Produkt
Billard
cool oder nein
ich schwöre wenn ich das Ding hochnehme
Rollen ihn alle Richtungen oh Alter für
2 € geht das echt mega klar jetzt
spielen wir ein bisschen Billardfreunde
ne zack oh es ist drauf nur die weiße
eingelocht
Freunde wenn ihr mal eine Mini Billard
Challenge auf meinem Kanal sehen wollt
dann schreibt's mal in die Kommentare
dass man leichter weil hiermit kann man
das jetzt auf jeden Fall machen als
nächstes greife ich jetzt wieder einfach
mal in die Tüte so wie bei jedem Produkt
und als nächstes das letzte Party
[Applaus]
gemacht aber das Gute daran ist wenn man
eins kaputt macht beim Aufschneiden hat
man immer noch zwei weitere und zwar
macht jetzt einfach
die stinken so krass nach China das
tolle an den Teilen ist ist dass man
sich mit denen auch einfach selbst
einspringen kann nämlich
let's party
[Musik]
wir greifen wieder in die Tüte rein
meine Damen und Herren das heißt als
nächstes Produkt haben wir hier von Jule
gekauft bekommen ein
dicker du willst mich auch echt zum
Affen machen ne
Alter sehe ich beschissen aus als
nächstes Produkt haben wir hier
dicker willst du mich komplett baden
ja es macht so Spaß hier diese Brille
würde ich sagen kann Julia einfach mal
aufsetzen
geh dich einfach vergraben wir machen
natürlich direkt weiter mit dem nächsten
Produkt was wir hier vorfinden werden
und zwar du bist echt Party machen ne
das ist überhaupt der eigentlich ist gar
nicht mal so scheiße ne
2000 Jahre später
ja ich würde sagen das reicht dann auch
mal also Freunde wir befinden uns gerade
bei mir auf dem Balkon und ich werde
jetzt diese Wasserbombe einfach mal
dagegen schmeißen Jule bist du bereit
Freunde seid ihr bereit okay ihr könnt
nicht mit mir reden aber gut ich werfe
nun die Wasserbombe wow
[Musik]
das war sonderlich unspektakulär
eigentlich aber Freunde wir machen
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten Produkt
und zwar haben wir
ein eine Kinder Cola
ohne Koffein
hier warte Party Jule
da schmeckt wie dieses Cola Wassereis
geschmolzen
das ist nicht gut das nächste Produkt
aus dem 1 Euro Geschäft kommt sofort und
zwar ist es
dass es
ein Teleskopspiegel wenn ihr mich sehen
Jule ja Alter mega geil
also diesen teleskop-spiel glaube ich
auch keine Ahnung wofür ich den mal
irgendwann gebrauchen kann
wahrscheinlich
um die Ecke gucken dann haben wir jetzt
nächstes ist Luke schon raus
partyservietten wow Jule die Party kann
ja gar nicht mehr gestoppt werden was
hast du dir denn dabei gedacht diese
ganzen Sachen hier zu holen
[Musik]
ist kein Rechte irgendwas zu sagen so
wie das hier aussieht hättest du Bock
auf eine Party wir spielen Billard und
unser Hund kommt auch und dann hat er
was zu fressen damit der ruhig ist dann
haben wir Servietten weil wir da noch
aber wir machen weiter und zwar das
nächste Produkt ist nicht
komplett verarschen das ist Papier
das hast du 1 € ausgegeben das hast du
jetzt nicht gemacht
das ist voll schönes Geschenkpapier
eigentlich oder das auf jeden Fall auch
super toll und dann haben wir als
nächstes noch eine
ich weiß dass das ein Schweißband ist
Jule
hat Deutschland klebt an meinem Arm hier
meine Damen und Herren wir kommen nun
zum letzten Produkt was ich hier fühlen
kann und zwar ist es aus dem ein Euro
Geschäft was Jule gekauft
davon wusste und zwar haben wir als was
ist das
ja was ist das Kaugummi Kaugummi ja
zungenfärberkaugummi ja
Zehner wenn ich das jetzt esse wenn ich
gleich zu einem Familienessen muss
ja meine Damen und Herren
abschneiden ja meine Damen und Herren an
der Stelle wo ich das heutige Video dann
allerdings auch
wenn du eine andere hast wahrscheinlich
so Häufigkeit Leute
und dann setzt man die ab und dann denkt
man hat immer noch auf weil
wenn euch das Video gefallen hat und
nicht das eventuell noch mal machen soll
und sie noch mal andere Produkte kauft
dann lasst gerne mal ein Like da und
sonst
Kaugummi mir ist echt schlecht gerade
sowas zu machen juckt aber im Endeffekt
niemand